hey everyone today we're talking about
visual user interfaces pub sub lite next
22 and free cloud training i'm debbie
cabrera and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
at google cloud we're committed to
making artificial intelligence or ai
accessible to everyone and easier to
harness for new use cases that's why
we're excited to announce the general
availability of our intuitive new visual
user interface for google cloud speech
to text stt api
right in google cloud console which
makes the api much simpler and easier
for developers to use
when you build highly resilient data
analytics pipelines difficult trade-offs
are common increasing reliability can
come at a cost but then pursuing low
cost can mean more hands-on operational
management the cloud pub sub team wants
to give you the flexibility to optimize
for cost reliability and level of
management given your workload
so we're introducing an additional
messaging option that balances cost with
high availability this new pub sub light
offering is called regional topics
google cloud is now offering 30 days no
cost access to google cloud skills boost
the definitive destination for skills
development to complete role-based
training choose from eight learning
paths including getting started with
google cloud cloud engineer data analyst
ml engineer and more
hope you're ready for some excitement
because google cloud next returns on
october 11 through october 13th of this
year join us for keynotes from industry
luminaries and engage live with google
developers explore dynamic content
across various learning levels and dive
deep into technologies and solutions
spanning the google cloud and google
workspace portfolios you'll participate
in breakout sessions demos hands-on
training and hear from the world's
leading companies about their digital
transformation journeys you'll have
opportunities to connect with experts
get inspired and boost your skills
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud